Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Audrey Hamilton. In this episode, I talk with a psychologist about the obesity epidemic and why families can struggle to maintain healthy eating habits, especially older children and teens. So even if parents are doing a really good job of being role models at home, kids still have a really hard time, and their role models of their peers, which are important during adolescence, are often driving them to pretty unethical. healthful habits. It's not just about telling your kids to choose fruits over chips. Psychological research has a lot to offer in terms of how teens and their parents can be more mindful eaters, encouraging them to adopt healthier lifelong habits. Eleanor Mackey is a child psychologist with Children's National Medical Center in the Washington, D.C. area. She is also a member of the
您好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是一档由美国心理学会制作的播客。我是主持人奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。在本期节目中，我和一位心理学家讨论了肥胖流行病，以及为什么家庭在维持健康饮食习惯时会遇到困难，特别是对于较大的孩子和青少年。因此，即使父母在家里作为榜样做得非常好，孩子们仍然会遇到很大的困难，而他们在青春期很重要的同龄人榜样，往往会驱使他们养成非常不健康的习惯。这不仅仅是告诉你的孩子选择水果而不是薯片。心理学研究在如何让青少年及其父母更有正念地进食、鼓励他们养成更健康的终身习惯方面，有很多宝贵的建议。埃莉诺·麦基是华盛顿特区地区国家儿童医疗中心的儿童心理学家。她还是
Children's Obesity Institute, an interdisciplinary team of physicians, researchers, and mental health professionals committed to preventing childhood obesity. She counts. She counts. counselors children and teens who struggle with eating and weight problems and continues to conduct research on obesity treatment. Welcome Dr. Mackey. Thank you. We see a lot of focus on encouraging healthy eating habits in young children, which is understandable. We have young children. Young children are going to be fussier eaters. Parents want to make sure they're helping them develop healthy eating habits early in life. But what about teens? You know, what are some of the issues that bring older children into the clinic where you work and how do you help them? Well, I think you might be
儿童肥胖研究所的成员，这是一个由内科医生、研究人员和心理健康专业人员组成的跨学科团队，致力于预防儿童肥胖。她接待。她接待。她为与饮食和体重问题作斗争的儿童和青少年提供咨询，并继续开展肥胖治疗方面的研究。欢迎您，麦基医生。谢谢。我们看到很多焦点都集中在鼓励幼儿养成健康饮食习惯上，这是可以理解的。我们有幼儿。幼儿往往是挑食者。父母希望确保他们能帮助孩子在生命的早期培养健康的饮食习惯。但是青少年呢？你知道，有哪些问题把较大的孩子带到了你工作的诊所，你又是如何帮助他们的？嗯，我想你可能会
surprised that there are certainly picky eaters, many of them still as teenagers, and I think that presents their own unique challenges. And oftentimes we have kids come in who are just not eating enough variety of healthful foods or not engaging in exercise, and they've come to the attention of physicians because they've started developing difficulties and other medical conditions related to that. And so concerns about their health really drive them to our clinics. I guess admittedly encouraging healthier eating behaviors than older children is an uphill battle. You know, they're more independent. You know, you may not have sugary sodas in your refrigerator at home, but chances are their friends will or maybe at school, you know, who knows? You know, we live in a
感到惊讶的是，其中肯定有挑食者，他们中的许多人在十几岁时依然如此，我认为这带来了他们自己独特的挑战。而且通常情况下，我们会有这样的孩子来就诊，他们摄入的健康食物种类不够多，或者不参加锻炼，他们引起了医生的注意，因为他们开始出现困难以及与之相关的其他医疗状况。因此，对他们健康的担忧真正促使他们来到了我们的诊所。我想，不可否认的是，鼓励较大的孩子养成更健康的饮食行为是一场硬仗。你知道，他们更独立了。你知道，你家里可能没有含糖苏打水，但他们的朋友家里很可能有，或者在学校里，谁知道呢？你知道，我们生活在一个
culture where fast food is everywhere. Do you see the trend toward more healthy foods trickling down to teens, or, you know, how can parents encourage that at home? I think you're right that that's such a challenge, and I think kids are still surrounded by an unhealthy eating culture, and a lot of kids come back to our clinics and tell us that a lot of their social events revolve around food. They go out to eat with their friends or different activities that they're at include unhealthful foods. So even if parents are doing a really good job of being role models at home and making sure that the food environment at home is full of plenty of easily available and good tasting healthy foods, kids still have a really hard time and their role models of their peers, which are
快餐无处不在的文化中。你是否看到向更健康食物转变的趋势逐渐渗透到青少年当中，或者说，父母如何在家里鼓励这种趋势？我想你是对的，这是一个巨大的挑战，而且我认为孩子们仍然被不健康的饮食文化所包围，许多孩子回到我们的诊所告诉我们，他们的许多社交活动都围绕着食物展开。他们和朋友出去吃饭，或者他们参加的不同活动都包含不健康的食物。因此，即使父母在家里作为榜样做得非常好，并确保家里的食物环境充满了充足、易得且美味的健康食物，孩子们仍然会遇到很大的困难，而他们的同龄人榜样，
important during adolescence, are often driving them to pretty unhealthful habits. So what sort of methods or what sort of techniques do you use? with these teens who are struggling in those environments. I think it's important to make sure that you sort of tackle it on two different fronts. One is to actually make sure that the home environment is helpful and that parents are providing the right type of support to their kids. So it's not very helpful if a parent nags a kid or makes them feel bad about the poor choices that they're making, but rather in a supportive way enables them to make healthier choices.
在青春期非常重要，却往往驱使他们养成相当不健康的习惯。那么，你对这些在这些环境中苦苦挣扎的青少年使用什么样的方法或技术呢？我认为重要的是确保你从两个不同的战线来解决这个问题。一是确保家庭环境是有益的，并且父母为他们的孩子提供了正确类型的支持。因此，如果父母唠叨孩子或者让他们为自己所做的糟糕选择感到难过，这是没有多大帮助的，相反，应该以一种支持的方式使他们能够做出更健康的选择。
And sometimes this can be as simple as making sure that food is actually available in the house or that the foods when you first open the refrigerator or the pantry are the good options, or make sure that they've portioned foods correctly so that if a kid is grabbing a snack, that they're not grabbing the huge bag of chips, that maybe they have an individual serving-sized bag of nuts. Those types of things parents can do. They can try and structure the environment in a way that's helpful without nagging, and they can be good role models themselves.
有时这可以很简单，比如确保家里确实有食物，或者当你第一次打开冰箱或食品储藏室时，里面的食物就是好的选择，或者确保他们正确分配食物分量，这样如果孩子拿零食，他们拿的不是一大袋薯片，而可能是一小包坚果。这些是父母可以做的事情。他们可以尝试以一种有益的方式构建环境而不唠叨，他们自己也可以成为好榜样。
But then when we're thinking about the influence of peers, often what we have to do is work individually with the teens themselves, And a lot of the work that we do as psychologists is really helping kids stay motivated to take care of themselves and engage in behaviors that are good for them and help them find reasons for keeping themselves healthy. Because a lot of what you're talking about, a nutritionist can tell you those things. But what you're just touched on right now is why psychologists are so important and mental health experts are so important in this process because it's not just about saying, eat this, eat that, don't eat this, don't eat that.
但是，当我们考虑到同龄人的影响时，我们通常必须与青少年本身进行个别工作，作为心理学家，我们所做的许多工作实际上是帮助孩子保持动力去照顾自己，参与对他们有益的行为，并帮助他们找到保持健康的理由。因为你所谈论的大部分内容，营养师都可以告诉你。但你刚才触及的正是为什么心理学家在这个过程中如此重要，心理健康专家如此重要，因为这不仅仅是关于说，吃这个，吃那个，不要吃这个，不要吃那个。
It's about changing the mindset. Yeah, absolutely. I think it's all about making helpful choices, and psychologists are really experts on why people make the choices that they do and helping restructure the way they think about things or where the behaviors are driven by environmental factors, restructuring the environment to help make healthy choices be the easier choices or the more readily taken choices.
这是关于改变心态。是的，绝对是。我认为这全关乎做出健康的抉择，而心理学家确实是关于人们为什么会做出某种选择的专家，他们能帮助重构人们对事物的看法，或者在行为由环境因素驱动时，重构环境以帮助健康的抉择成为更容易的抉择或更乐意采纳的抉择。
What about the emotional aspect of it? I mean, I imagine some kids using food as an emotional support system. see that a lot? I think it's almost universal that people use food as coping. And when you think back to the little kids, parents often structure things that way. They reward kids with dessert or going out to eat or an unhealthful treat. And from an early age, we're set up to expect that food, especially unhealthful but tasty foods, are a reward. And there's a lot of good research showing that those types of foods activate those same regions of the brain that are reward-driven in the same way that drugs and alcohol might.
那情感方面呢？我的意思是，我想象有些孩子把食物当作情感支持系统。你经常看到这种情况吗？我认为人们用食物来应对压力几乎是普遍现象。回想一下小孩子，父母经常这样安排事情。他们用甜点、出去吃饭或不健康的零食来奖励孩子。从小到大，我们都被灌输这样一种期望：食物，尤其是那些不健康但美味的食物，是一种奖励。有许多好的研究表明，这些类型的食物会激活大脑中那些受奖励驱动的区域，其方式与毒品和酒精可能产生的影响相同。
And so we set up the environment for kids to reinforce that, and our brains are already driven in that way. So by the time you get to adolescence, you often see that reward-driven eating, and you also see eating to cope. And we all know that adolescents can be a stressful time, that kids go to school and may get in arguments with their peers or may have stress related to their schoolwork.
因此，我们为孩子们建立了强化这种行为的环境，我们的大脑也已经以这种方式受到驱动。所以到了青春期，你经常会看到这种受奖励驱动的饮食，你也会看到为了应对情绪而进食。我们都知道青春期可能是一个充满压力的时期，孩子们去学校可能会与同龄人争吵，或者可能会有与学业有关的压力。
And oftentimes what they do is they come home, and we often see the school day structured so that kids have a long break, between when they have lunch and when they come home. They're often starving by the time they get home. They may be tired and have less self-control, and they may also be experiencing a variety of negative emotions related to their school day.
通常他们会回家，我们经常看到学校的一天安排是，孩子们在吃午饭和回家之间有一个漫长的休息。他们到家时往往饿极了。他们可能很累，自控力较差，他们可能还经历着与学校生活相关的各种负面情绪。
And all of those things create the perfect storm for overeating or loss of control eating when they get home, and it can become kind of a vicious cycle. Mental health experts like you and even parents, they're really struggling, I think, to straddle a line between body shaming and helping kids behave in a way that's best for their own bodies and their own health.
所有这些因素交织在一起，为他们到家后暴饮暴食或失控进食创造了完美的风暴，这可能会演变成一种恶性循环。像你这样的心理健康专家，甚至父母，我认为他们真的在艰难地走钢丝，一方面要避免身材羞辱，另一方面要帮助孩子以最有利于他们身体和健康的方式行事。
eating disorders are especially common among teens as we know. How can parents navigate those tricky waters? I think that's really important, and I think the key take home for families is that encouraging your child to have high self-esteem and making them feel good about themselves is the best way to have them want to take care of themselves. So if you don't talk about weight or appearance, but instead focus on health and well-being, kids are much more likely to buy into that idea and not have the negative feedback that they get from weight. So if you have a parent who approaches it by saying,
如我们所知，饮食失调在青少年中尤其普遍。父母该如何应对这些棘手的问题？我认为这非常重要，我认为给家庭的核心启示是，鼓励你的孩子建立高度的自尊，让他们对自己感觉良好，是让他们想要照顾自己的最佳方式。因此，如果你不谈论体重或外表，而是专注于健康和福祉，孩子们更有可能接受这一理念，并且不会从体重中获得负面反馈。所以，如果你的父母采用这种方法说：
honey, I think you are a little bit overweight or you need to start working on your weight, let's change the way we eat, that's going to have a whole series of negative emotions that comes along with it, and it's going to end up becoming more of a problem than help. And we often see well-meaning parents go down that route. But if that same well-meaning parent instead said, I feel like as a family we're really not taking care of ourselves. We're eating a lot more junk food than we need to, and I feel like it's really not helping
亲爱的，我觉得你有点超重了，或者你需要开始控制体重了，让我们改变饮食方式吧，这会带来一连串的负面情绪，最终会变成一个更多的问题而不是帮助。我们经常看到好心的父母走这条路。但是，如果这位同样好心的父母转而说，我觉得作为一家人，我们真的没有照顾好自己。我们吃的垃圾食品比我们需要的要多得多，我觉得这真的没有帮助
us be healthy. I can tell that we're just running out of energy or having trouble focusing. As a family, we're really going to take better care of ourselves because we're important and you're important to me, and here's how we're going to do it. And I think that that sends a very different message, and I think the more you promote good self-esteem and desire to take care of yourself, the better off you'll be. Yeah, that's great advice. You mentioned that the family really, the conversation has to be directed as a family effort.
我们保持健康。我能看出我们正在失去精力，或者难以集中注意力。作为一个家庭，我们要真正照顾好自己，因为我们很重要，你对我也很重要，我们要这样做。我认为这传递了一个非常不同的信息，而且我认为你越是促进良好的自尊心和照顾自己的渴望，你就会过得越好。是的，这是极好的建议。你提到过，家庭真的，谈话必须作为家庭共同的努力来引导。
Why is that so important in the process of getting teens to be healthier? Well, teenagers especially are really self-conscious. They tend to feel that everyone is focused on them and they often feel singled out, and that can be a pretty negative experience. And so if you have a kid and a family who's struggling with healthy eating or weight, the worst thing you can do is make them feel singled out or different, because of that difficulty. And so we often counsel families to try and make any change as a family
为什么这在让青少年变得更健康的过程中如此重要？嗯，尤其是青少年，他们有着极强的自我意识。他们倾向于认为每个人都把焦点集中在他们身上，而且他们经常觉得自己被孤立了，这可能是一种相当消极的体验。因此，如果你有一个孩子和一个在健康饮食或体重问题上苦苦挣扎的家庭，你能做的最糟糕的事情就是让他们因为这种困难而觉得自己被孤立或与众不同。所以我们经常建议家庭尝试作为整体做出任何改变
rather than singling out one kid or making sure that it's not just one kid who's not allowed to have dessert. That as a family, you make a decision that you're going to eat healthier. And so it's really important that parents not nag or not single out and make sure that they focus on the whole family and family-wide changes in order to be supportive. I've also seen research suggesting there's a link between dietary habits and mental health. what do we know about how mental health and diet are linked? There's a lot of good research showing about diet and about exercise.
而不是单挑出一个孩子，或者确保不仅仅是一个孩子不被允许吃甜点。而是作为一个家庭，你们做出决定要吃得更健康。因此，父母不唠叨、不孤立，并确保他们关注整个家庭和全家范围内的改变以提供支持，这一点非常重要。我还看到有研究表明饮食习惯与心理健康之间存在联系。我们对心理健康和饮食之间的联系了解多少？有很多很好的研究展示了饮食和运动的情况。
And all of us can sort of relate. If you have a day that you're eating unhealthfully grabbing stuff on the go, not having fruits, vegetables, protein, you start dragging. Your energy levels are low. We know that it can affect the way you think and how quickly you are to react to things. And it just changes a lot about your emotions. It can also change the way you sleep. And sleep, as we know, has a big impact on emotions.
我们所有人都能感同身受。如果你有一天饮食不健康，匆忙抓起食物应付，没有吃水果、蔬菜、蛋白质，你就会开始感到疲惫。你的精力水平很低。我们知道这会影响你的思维方式以及你对事物的反应速度。它改变了你对情绪的很多看法。它还会改变你的睡眠方式。正如我们所知，睡眠对情绪有很大的影响。
We also know that exercise really helps promote better well-being and can lift mood. And so if you've got a kid who's not eating very well, who's not exercising very much, it definitely can translate into mood. And oftentimes some of the things we recommend for kids who are experiencing depression are to eat at regular times, healthy foods to get out and exercise. And those things do seem to help mood. Yeah, I mean, their hormones are already at a level that, you know, they're having a hard time adjusting.
我们还知道，运动确实有助于促进更好的身心健康并能提升情绪。因此，如果你有一个孩子吃得不好、运动不多，这绝对会转化为情绪问题。通常我们对经历抑郁症的孩子推荐的一些做法是定时定量地吃饭、吃健康的食物、出门运动。这些事情似乎确实有助于改善情绪。是的，我的意思是，他们的荷尔蒙已经处于这样一个水平，你知道，他们很难适应。
I can see that. Now, part of your work is also counseling teens who are considering bariatric surgery, which is when doctors reduce the size of the stomach with a gastric band or the removal of a portion of the stomach. Can you explain briefly what, you know, this type of surgery is and why it's so important for anyone considering this procedure to consult with a psychologist like you? I think it's important to note that kids who go through bariatric surgery have a different disease than kids who are just struggling with their weight. So overweight or even class one obesity, which is sort of the lower end of obesity, that's also a chronic illness, but it's something that generally is managed with the help of a doctor through lifestyle management. When you start seeing severe obesity, which is the fastest growing category of obesity among kids and teens, that's when you start to get to a body mass index of 35 or greater, and it comes along with a lot of other health problems. It has a big impact on quality of life and increases risk for type 2 diabetes, hypertension.
我能理解这一点。现在，你工作的一部分还包括为考虑减重手术的青少年提供咨询，这种手术是通过胃束带或切除一部分胃来缩小胃的容量。你能简要解释一下，这种手术是什么，为什么任何考虑这个程序的人咨询像你这样的心理学家都如此重要吗？我认为重要的是要注意，经历减重手术的孩子与那些仅仅在与体重作斗争的孩子患有不同的疾病。因此，超重甚至是I度肥胖（这是肥胖的较低端），这也是一种慢性疾病，但它通常是通过医生在生活方式管理方面的帮助来控制的。当你开始看到严重肥胖（这是儿童和青少年中增长最快的肥胖类别）时，你的体重指数（BMI）就会达到35或更高，并且它伴随着许多其他健康问题。它对生活质量有很大的影响，并增加了患2型糖尿病、高血压的风险。
a number of other problems. The problem is that a lot of the treatments we have for overweight and obesity don't work for severe obesity. So lifestyle management, just changing the way kids are eating and exercise, are very likely to not be successful with severe obesity. So the one treatment that has emerged as the most effective treatment for severe obesity is bariatric surgery. But it certainly does change the way that you're able to eat.
以及许多其他问题。问题在于，我们针对超重和肥胖的许多治疗方法对严重肥胖无效。因此，生活方式管理，即改变孩子们的饮食方式和运动，极不可能对严重肥胖成功。因此，作为治疗严重肥胖最有效的疗法脱颖而出的是减重手术。但这确实改变了你进食的能力。
It changes your anatomy, and it changes a lot about your life, sometimes for the better, but sometimes not in ways that kids expect. And so we have kids meet with the psychologist prior to surgery to make sure that they understand the process, to make sure that they are able to provide consent, and to identify any areas where we might be able to provide recommendations to increase their likelihood of success following surgery. Okay, well, Dr. Mackey, thank you so much for joining us. It's been a real pleasure. Thank you. Thanks for listening to our podcast.
它改变了你的解剖结构，并极大地改变了你的生活，有时是朝着更好的方向发展，但有时并不是孩子们预期的那样。因此，我们让孩子们在手术前与心理学家见面，以确保他们理解整个过程，确保他们能够提供知情同意，并找出我们能够提供建议以增加他们手术成功可能性的任何领域。好的，麦基医生，非常感谢您加入我们。这真是令人愉快。谢谢。感谢收听我们的播客。
Make sure you check out our other episodes of Speaking of Psychology, and please subscribe if you haven't already. We are a proud member of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts. Please check out APA Journal's Dialogue if you want to hear about the latest and most exciting psychology research. And if you're interested in the practice of psychology, you can listen to Progress Notes. Topics include how health care policy and social media affect practicing psychologists. You can find those podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speaking ofpsychology.org, to listen to even more episodes and gather more resources on the topics we discussed. Thanks for joining us. I'm Audrey Hamilton with the American
请务必查看我们《心理学谈话》的其他剧集，如果您还没有订阅，请订阅。我们是APA播客网络的自豪成员，其中包含其他精彩的播客。如果您想听到最新、最令人兴奋的心理学研究，请查看APA期刊的《对话》（APA Journal's Dialogue）。如果您对心理学实践感兴趣，可以收听《进展记录》（Progress Notes）。主题包括医疗保健政策和社交媒体如何影响执业心理学家。您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或您获取播客的任何地方找到这些播客。您也可以访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org，收听更多剧集，并收集有关我们讨论话题的更多资源。感谢您的加入。我是美国心理学会的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿
Psychological Association, and this is Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里是《心理学谈话》。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。